hey guys it is monday the fifth of
October today my name is Jess and you're
watching games dice has dispelled
speculation about star wars battlefront
by confirming there will be no
microtransactions in the upcoming
multiplayer game battlefront uses a
currency system that is made up of
points and credits credits will be used
to rent more exotic and dangerous
weapons we often see two tiered currency
systems like these in games designed to
incorporate micro transactions but
battlefront designer Nicholas for Grace
had said this is not the case for
battlefront he explains the currency
system is based on your game performance
the credits that you use to buy things
in the game are earned you play the game
complete challenges and that how you get
credits he added that micro transactions
are not part of the game's core designs
and if you want to earn points and
subsequently credits you can simply play
the game all complete different
challenges call Jeannie black ops 3
appears to be adding a presumably super
difficult realistic mode for the first
time in the franchise the trophy list
for black ops 3 was published by
achievement site EXO phase which
mentions a spa called realistic mode
this appears to be the game's new and
hardest setting above the usual hardened
and veteran treyarch is yet to confirm
any specific details as to what the new
difficulty setting may entail other
clues within the trophy list suggests
that the dead ops arcade minigame will
make every appearance and the maximum
multiplayer level will be 55 black ops 3
launches on november six Ubisoft is
teasing a new game today and thanks to
the Internet where nothing is secret we
probably have a pretty good idea of what
it is while patient fans have been
painstakingly watching cave drawings and
listening to eerie music growling beasts
and chanting on ubisoft's YouTube live
stream for hours it seems as if IG and
Turkey has accidentally leaked the news
on their official Twitter page they
posted what might be supposedly the
first image of Far Cry primal the next
installment in the Far Cry
series the page has now been taken down
at the time of recording and nothing
official has been said from Ubisoft so
we're down in the comments what you
think of Ubisoft announcements you
should head the game spot where you can
find stories on quantum breaks delay and
a ps4 price drop that is everything I
happy today be sure to let me know what
matter to you and I'll catch against
morrow